I think we were pioneers in
external communication, just
show more say more what are we doing, where are
we going and so on and when I
think back, that was the right
way, so it wasn't the plan
that I would get influenza or something like that
but it was more the plan that we
can communicate via this social media perception hey we do
business here and there and so on and
if you have something good offer us
and there has been a lot of business via social
media in the last few years
and okay us  maybe we didn't
just make friends because the
real estate industry was of course
very discreet and withdrawn when we started when I started,
that has
just changed via LinkedIn and the whole
platform,
but if I were to do the whole thing all over again
then I would  now we
see that we have even more followers yes
because it has disappeared a good
decision
to be a first mover right now so also
before insta and so on yes when I
heard or saw more of Jakob for the first time
I thought so to myself  be
satire someone kidding because
real estate agent the whole thing was very
boastful very doll i
took a closer look then understood okay it can
really be that he does the bigger
deals and i became curious
was generally curious to see why
business works with me i
went there  and was then quite flabbergasted
yes he says that partly ironic or something
does but doesn't do everything at the same time
really does that can a small
at least very very big
real estate deal i learned a lot
and in the end he acted a bit
vulnerable now let's
talk to jakoben  let's go,
welcome, yes, hello,
welcome, just a couple of
corrections to that, I'm incredibly
rich when it comes to debts,
okay, but you're still a self-made
real estate entrepreneur, at least once
correctly, exactly, yes,
I've been working in the industry for 21 years after my graduation, exactly
directly
wish or  did you stumble in there
so I always wanted to be independent
it was always where to act if you
enjoyed doing things independently
so no idea to plan or
anything so I noticed early on in
the years that I don't like being
told what to do  I didn't have to do that
and um, my
brother got me into the stock market during my graduation
and then I
started speculating with a small amount on the stock exchange right after my graduation. I
had my first money together and that
was when
the phase came  The market is volatile and you
could basically still do it relatively easily
online
and that’s when I earned my first money
but then I was a bit
scared to be honest where is
the future going and then
I thought about buying an apartment that was
very cheap at the time  still 37,000 € to
costettenstraße 14 in Berlin Tegel
exactly and that was my first
real estate investment more or less
half a year still in high school
and then my mother asked me boy
what do you actually do I mean
good news I'm not only a
day trader but also  still
real estate investors then everything started
okay that means but you already knew yourself
so training studying is not
for you of course everything
developed it happened yes I didn’t
sit down at the age of 18 I
made a plan and said that’s how
mine is developing now  Life or
the industry, so there has always been
life somewhere with a plan that I had
continuously readjusted, so I
said okay,
what is it all about now and of
course I couldn’t have guessed where
Berlin would develop when I
bought my first mobile
and after that I sold and my first
rental house and so on and basically who
laid the foundation for the
group of companies today was of course not
foreseeable or I could not
foresee where this city would develop
at that time the prices were totally down
and erm Berlin was  poor and sexy and uh
but back then the first apartment
you say 30,000 35 and then you got how much
work for it 65 ok well it
happens normal apartment was cheap
very cheap and told a little bit back
then I laughed and more because
you idiot what do you do  you there real estate it
will never develop anyway and uh
I actually have to fight more with the
headwind from the people who
had in the area and where did you
notice that what is happening to you
my that the apartment is rented and
then came renovated  To be honest, I was
with a friend at the weekend
and then I really hung this whole
bottle of classic neon signs in there
to sell these orange neons.
Then one
person really got in touch and this one person
then asked what the apartment costs,
then I'll do 98,000
or  99,000, I then
went down to 98 and then
made my first mobile deal with it, okay, that
means you then somehow earned almost 60,000 through the renovation
and through selling one,
yes I
more or less doubled the
condition was [ __ ], so exactly
okay and then I started with
rental houses
the time between buying uh
selling because there are still a few
months exactly two three months or something
okay that's of course already then
I found really good developers, that's why
they're here today
but then you've got yourself  Looking at houses,
yes, that sounds very dramatic from
today's perspective, but you have to know
that back then, mobile prices
were completely down and even a
rental house, i.e. a classic
apartment building with its 618 parties,
cost 200,000 euros or something at that time, yes, and that was then for me
affordable because they got it from the
banks what the money was at the
beginning I did everything, which means the
first cash was then somehow this
60,000 € or something exactly and at the same time
you have to know I still
did stock market transactions and because
that was money-making  it was relatively easy to do back then,
you can’t compare it to today, back
then you could
do your high school diploma, so
buy cheap and sell more expensive because
there were just so many market differences on the market, it’s
no longer possible today than
you have computers, this technology but
back then it was simpler, okay, and  then
you took this money and then
bought it in the right way and then
sold it again, developed it
and rehabilitated it yourself was more
difficult so I don’t have to
put my hands on it, I have to put my head in it, but yes, I
then worked with construction companies and so on to
whip things into shape  but basically I
started out really small so it was really
out of the children's room
had a small office and so on
and
then really small style still
made of what sold at the beginning I
also messed around a bit so
investment real estate brokers are a feeling
for wars who buys what  and so
on, that means someone had to answer you about
their space first,
that you
market it, yes, no, then you automatically get to
know people, yes, and then I met today
who wanted to invest in Berlin,
and after the first two or three
years  and then I
worked for them to build up the portfolio, so
portfolio means a mobile package and
then I worked for the gentlemen here, did
that and at the same time
still did some stock exchange transactions,
which then at some point over the years
shut down, I just concentrated on mobile
business and on  In the beginning I
just took over the advice from third parties
or just this real estate portfolio
structure and did my own things at the same time and
then
just about from 2627 let this
consulting portfolio business be
and then in the end I only
concentrate on my own projects but only
in Berlin exactly basically I have up to
Yes, let's just say about 10 years ago,
only Berlin did it because back then it was extremely
attractive here. The city has
continued to develop positively over the years
and it was cheap to get into the market.
Berlin was also a very
liberal market, what I mean by that  want to say
is if you
look at the real estate market in Munich or
in Hamburg, for example, he is already in a kind of
close job, so Hamburg I will
you live in Hamburg yes
was always a wealthy city was
always a contact point for wealthy
speakers and so on  Entrepreneurs back
and forth and that wasn't the case in Berlin back then,
so after the division of the wise
whole market there were
many projects there was simply the
possibility more or less I call
it for everyone to go into the market
yes and a lot of offers a lot and
what you have  so you then made houses apartment there was
any search profile
or what yes we clearly had what you
want to sell or you want to buy
as centrally as possible real estate that can
ideally be rented or that
you can rent if you
restore it so its renovated
buy cheap
for example  I mean,
maybe you know a bit of nightlife from
one of our houses was
Brückenstrasse, more precisely from the entrance to the
KitKatClub, so yes, on the other side,
okay, and then you sometimes did it with
money, at some point you
still had real estate, so that you then had
a  Bank okay, I didn't know myself
very well either, no, I like to tell
the story today of how well everything
went, but at the beginning I
made all the mistakes that
can be made, so I had no idea about the wrong
tax structure, I didn't really
have a plan to manage it, so that
I naturally
grew more and more into this industry from year to year,
of course, it wasn’t easy at the beginning either,
I mean as a 21-22-year-old and where it
matters says I’ll
buy a rental house here first, I’ve often found
myself sitting in the office  and
the appointment doesn't start because someone
stays where because now several yes, it's me
[laughter]
a lot you also learn to assert yourself a bit
and
over the years I think I got
better but the business also became
more difficult and say yes then came
yes  at some point, the first crisis
around Liman shortly before, I fortunately had
sold some properties and then had
liquidity and then invested a lot in
Neukölln because I
thought Neukölln had many
other B and C locations in Berlin
and where do you get these properties  always
here so you have to know that there
are just quite normal
online platforms and and
what is there right now or or is the
internet the streets or how did you
write to Immoscout or brokers in the old days about something very classic and so on and so on
especially in the beginning it was very
easy because there were hardly any buyers and erm there
was a massive oversupply yes and then
it was relatively easy
to get real estate that back then you had to have
a very simple search profile when
he just switched he
got some of your things  I
said okay I can only
afford it up to 250,000 euros anyway, then they were
just these mobile offers and
if they were cheap I then
tried to negotiate quickly and
bring in liability I mean
at the beginning I didn’t have that much of a
clue either, I think  I also simply overlooked a lot of
things, I think that was
also to the advantage of the deal, but
one of our I don't want to say our,
I'm talking in the interests of me and my
company was always speed,
commitment and gratitude,
so then also
viewing the deal and then
saying you buy  or maybe even
say in advance you buy but
saw the data directly yes and that was
just the way it was in the first phase I think it's
a good situation to
do business in the end it's
really easy to have done it
because it doesn't sound like it  so difficult,
but you just need the feeling and the
trust and the gut feeling
maybe for the for the areas and
that arose with you from
doing
as if you would answer this question in a differentiated way
it's just like that when
I was the mobile business as well  When I
did stock exchange business it was
relatively easy and then the
real estate business was also relatively
easy there were other challenges
back then, so back then we knew in
having a barbecue to somehow attract
tenants in Neukölln in the first place
that they would pay €5.50
then they became our bratwurst with Prosecco
lured us on Saturday and then
we somehow
managed to rent three apartments in a half-empty house
and that was kind of a
champagne mood for us yes
ok so going there the market has
changed so today you don't need to
tie up a bratwurst it's
the challenge you hold
today it's much more complex, so with
all the regulation energetically
renovating
rent control whatever all
sorts of regulators that
politicians dictate, that just didn't exist back then,
so back then
the only challenge you
had was finding a house when you found it
I say calculate more or less on
the beer coaster whether it
makes sense or not and then the
challenge was to rent the thing
and then later, when I
started doing bigger things,
logically to buy, to finance
and to rent and uhm yes then
basically to manage things, to
develop them further and to sell them at the right
time and in the
beginning we often sold on a smaller
scale, sometimes one house or sometimes
three houses or sometimes five houses
together as a package and then it became
about the  This business got bigger and bigger over the years,
which later
basically ended in the portfolio structure
and then we built up a mobile
portfolio or various portfolios
and then sold them globally,
so that you just had no idea
1000 apartments in Berlin and
then all of them in one fell swoop  sold an
institutional investor okay
[music]
we have more or
less 2,000 apartments at the company, a little more than 2,000
apartments and but in total in your
life you have already bought 4,5,000
yes, I think a lot more,
so I can't say right now  how
many apartments we bought but
there were already several thousand
apartments and I think that if we
target all transactions together
but the website is I believe
I or
the company did somewhere in the range of 23 billion transaction volume yes okay that means you
just have at some point  seen that is
always better and the banks
brought in and simply larger objects
made even more objects so as one
imagines,
the real estate business was
not that complicated at all because
there were enough offers at the time there was
later more and more willingness of the
To finance banks in Berlin, at
some point the market started
to function on the tenant side,
i.e. the houses were not just empty,
which was a big challenge for us at the beginning
and um that was a moment when I
said scale up
yes and later it was  it then
clearly but somehow houses well we
basically always
checked that we
sell properties individually or as a package
what should your sizes
we sold to a larger
Swedish investor at that time Bernburg
earned quite well so package of
100 apartments or yes exactly then at the
end there were 1000
more apartments okay later we
also sold another investor what
can you read in the press so those
were good deals yes but are they
essentially all
private apartments or so we have  did
n't do much business so compared
to what we did in the living area,
in the last two decades we were
mainly out and about in the living area
why
yes good question
honestly started with sausage life back then
and sold currywurst
I would probably have
currywurst stalls today and then I would say
yes  well sorry i don't know sushi or
anything yes
i was able to live and just
scaled it up
today we also do business today
we do industrial real estate and
commercial real estate and so on but
our or my expertise was above
all we are the classic
tenement house in Berlin  I knew my way around and
at some point I also had a certain
perception on the market that people
knew okay Jakob Bern buys a
rental house or several houses or a
residential complex or something like that the things were
offered to us and I think it was also
quite good that we stayed for a good while
always had a clear profile what we are
looking for
communicate internally what we can and
logically also towards the banks
so if you go to a bank then
say hello I am buying a meadow here
I am buying a skyscraper here I am buying
a house I am buying a gas station or
something like that is also possible but that's
a lot more confusing than when you say
we're buying rental houses it says on
my business card and just a
clear profile yeah
okay and at some point you also
started saying that what
you're doing is going to be made public, so to speak,
I mean  meanwhile you are
also you can almost say influenza
in that area you can say the situation
was when we
turn back time yes back when I
started in real estate yes
I didn't have a name yes I didn't have
a lot of money yes
mine too  Age or my expertise does
n't tell me in
any way either,
that means yes, I basically went
into publicity more broadly right from the start,
we
wrote to many brokers, we simply
tried to communicate more so that I could talk
about my name and my
group of companies  got a certain
perception of the market and then at
some point social media came along, that wasn’t
Instagram, there weren’t any
influencers, I like to remember
the times when Facebook
was very popular and then we
also had a strong Facebook account
with several  AG or at that time
several groups if you just one
and then always posted these sales contracts
so we bought that bought
that and and then only the
beginners were smiled at so today when
I look at LinkedIn half of
LinkedIn is full of porters yes but
we  were there one of the first or they
were the first to do it
and of course they got a certain
perception on the market it was
always like that I think
some have a quiet demeanor we had
a louder one and there were certainly people
who didn’t do business with us  that's why we
agreed, but
we approached other circles,
especially brokers, so brokers are
more likely to be
driven by a bit more money than others
when you
say somewhere on social media, of course, hey we buy here,
we did something there, back and forth
then what happened  of course quickly this
perception just in the maklershof oh
wow they buy I'll offer you something
and made a lot of business about it
even today uh it's like that then
Facebook became then at some point
Instagram Instagram then
basically has Facebook over in the perception
outdated and of course
it's not company-oriented
but of course people-
related yes and then I might have a certain polarization about
my perception on the market
your profile there it's like
someone who has nothing to hide now
who also has one  enjoys a certain level of prosperity
and that is already recognizable yes
easy to understand yes is also
as far as i think but then i see i am
not trying to step on anyone i
try not to be a person
who says i have i have i have
gone a better way  as someone else
i have made a lot of mistakes i have
also had to do a lot in my life
maybe because i subjected my job to my
or life to my job
giving up things but definitely
lost and so on
no idea no kids didnt
build a family because i  I didn't have time
for it, so
sometimes I do
n't necessarily look at
the live stable I have, but they
've created something in other areas, so
I'm also
impressed by this performance,
I didn't have the time for that, so there's
always something left open  the
route
but I said to myself okay what what do
I want to achieve with my
social media appearance or appearances
we want to be noticed in the market
we want to be positioned so
that we can say what we are looking for
so we are buying rental houses here and there
or we are  now
gone to Essen yes and my hometown
yes exactly the cool people
[laughter]
but okay why more or less
centrally we have there on the
Rückenscheider Straße and a good
office and so on and we
started investing there two years ago
and just have  needed a local presence
and that worked out well and
yes, but that
of course also helps a lot with something like that social media yes
and uh I think we were
pioneers in
external communication just show more say more what are
we doing where are we going  and so
on and when I think back it was
the right way so now it was
n't the plan that I would get influenza
or something but it was more the plan
that we could communicate through this social media
perception hey we
do business here and there and  so
on and if you have something cool
offer us and there has been a lot of business
via social media in
recent years and okay, we
may not only have made friends,
because the real estate industry was of course
very
discreet and reserved when we started  That has
just changed via LinkedIn and the
big platform,
but if I were to do the whole thing all over again,
I would now
make sure that we have even more followers,
because it was a good
decision
to be a first mover there
just before insta and so on
yes
the journey for the company will go on so
I first did Berlin
your strongest market until today but then
still decided to do
other people also eat exactly it
was just like that at some point we have um we
have like  I said a lot of Berlin and
then at some point
the business I wrote
scaled up bought rental houses basically
started their own
asset management, i.e. to build up a
management company for the real estate
on the strong acquisition team
built up a construction department
and so on and  then
umm we sold one or two larger
real estate portfolios in Berlin
so we made money or
made money
then I said okay what’s
going on in Berlin now, in a way,
so if we had our structures here
and our perception and
so on and then  we
basically ventured into East Germany, even
at a relatively early stage when, for
example, Magdeburg, Dresden, Leipzig,
Frankfurt or the
surrounding area of ​​Berlin and so on
was very cheap, yes, and then we basically have
exactly the same thing, a copy
and pace system from  Berlin has just been transferred to these
locations
Berlin is already an exception I do
n't know if everyone from Germany moment
if they all have a
housing shortage so it was it is so
the development in East Germany has
exceeded my own expectations yes I mean it was in Berlin
at some point so that I
noticed okay the demand for rented accommodation
is relatively high you can still
seize good opportunities here and there if you know the market well yes and I
had thought okay well I would
n’t move to Magdeburg now either although it’s
actually only a  the location is nice
but there was a lot on offer it was
still relatively cheap and so on and
then basically that for example the
Magdeburg development overtook my own
opinion was good for our
stock but I wouldn’t have seen it like that
or for example Leipzig in the
In combination with Halle,
Dresden has always been attractive, but it
was also in the so now we have
cities like Frankfurt or is already
more or less the smallest we have
100,000 or so yes we have so we
say more in the purchasing profile  than 50,000
inhabitants but better than 100 and
ideally something like
university campuses around where you have a good where
you
have jobs where the demographic
development is positive and so on
but of course I prefer to go to
Essen or to Dortmund or
whatever
played, of course  I mean the
low interest rate policy, which of
course has changed massively in the last year,
has of course
brought the whole market up, well,
the flood lifted all boats in the end,
probably didn't even
exist and this interest rate policy, well,
I started it 21
years ago  Well, back then I was
n't really interested in interest rates. I was
looking for a safe haven for myself when I was working on the stock exchange, yes, and then over the years
we've grown, the business
has expanded, I've tried to
professionalize it, I am myself  got
better got great colleagues
we have different companies
but in the several AG there are almost 70
yes yes
it will come when so
yes more or less okay what do you mean the
interest rates have helped
the interest rates have fueled the market
yes the interest rates  I mean when it was
of course also a perverse environment, so
you paid money if you gave your money
to the bank at the end of the year, so
negative interest and you could
borrow money more or less for nothing,
so one percent or three
percent or something, yes and that
of course, the market
accelerated massively and, especially in the investment sector
in Germany, it led to
prices rising over the years, yes,
of course, in
the big cities, the prices for
condominiums have gone down
discovered a lot of foreign capital
has flowed here the markets under
a round and of course that has
already led to the fact that these
real estate prices
have risen sharply across the board yes and now we have had
interest rate increases since last year, which in turn is putting a lot of pressure on
the market  yes, the investment
properties have certainly
fallen by 30% in the last 12 months,
so if you look at vonovia, one of the
largest German
courses, you
say that you have to see how you can
really get into a new world, so to speak, or
have to sell them or  So or are
you relaxed about the
current situation, so I think I
think everyone who is involved in real estate
at the moment and who is invested in real estate in a certain way
can't say that they're relaxed,
otherwise they've either had too little in
recent years  then done or
no idea so of course now
the real estate work really starts in my opinion
so not that you
simply win haphazardly with real estate because you once
bought a house you always have to wait two years
that was really the way it was in the last few
years so the prices are like that
it just kept rising and
unfortunately this has always
attracted thinner and thinner money and that
's already over yes now you have to
think about it and that's
starting to happen but the interest rate landscape in the
regulation in energy-efficient renovation
the construction prices are
strong with inflation  increased and so on
you can no longer rent to everyone
because of the rent cap and so on
so you have to
really think about where what makes
sense then we have the big topic of ESG
and so on and those are all
the points that then, for example  At
vonovia, the share price is depressing, of course,
above all, of course,
if you could refinance yourself with one percent two years ago
and now you have
paid three or borrowed
money on the
capital markets, which
has now tripled in costs or
something like that then you can see it in
reverse in the share prices yes and
that's not only the case with wohnover
but it's actually more or
less with all German
real estate shares so that they
have really corrected very strongly in the last 12 to 14 months 50%
60% 40% whatever, yes, but no
existential worries, so one could
also assume that you
have now financed say 100,000 apartments under the
old conditions and now all of a sudden they
will continue to be financed, but
then the conditions are now higher, the
interest conditions and all that  it can
really
bring about a complete slump for companies like that, so the share prices are
already painting a bleak picture,
yes, um, although of course
the stock markets always have expectations, yes,
and now of course you have to
take a close look, many of us
can't get an exact picture yet
show where the
interest rate landscape will be in a year, for example, yes
we have high inflation,
I understand that countermeasures
have to be taken somewhere, on the other hand,
all new buildings are collapsing, which is also a
big problem because new buildings are of course
only built when the
real estate market is stable and B
just somewhere can finance itself cheaply
or also has buyers at the back
and that's a certain explosiveness at the moment
for us it's like that we've
financed real estate we participate
in the strong demand for
rental apartments which isn't
increasing now rather than relaxing because we
have  Train from abroad we have
refugees unfortunately we are unfortunately at war
in the sense of Ukraine that is
then we
simply have more people moving to cities
and and and and
a
supply hole yes and that is
not increasing so this plan 400,000 apartments
or something  to build that
failed miserably and Essen will
really go into the basement again this year
yes
the normal market would say yes then
you can now increase the rents
as the owner uhm exactly
if you now have a new building then yes
it will work  but if you basically
want to rent out the property, you have
a rent control and that's it and
you can't just
turn a blind eye and say I
don't care, but then the tenants
basically also have a claim for repayment, so it's
the law and that's the way it is  Therefore
rent index maximum plus 10 percent and
that is the rent if we partially
let in Berlin we have 1000
applicants that is perverse if you
would think about what the
market actually has to offer but only because the
law is
over-regulated in my opinion and
this regulation  hits
this market right now, yes, and you have to take a
close look at what you are doing and that's what
I said before, so you ca
n't just run off
and say it doesn't matter what I get for it,
then you'll get problems with the
legislator but on  At the end of the day, if
you look at the situation like this,
it could well be that it is difficult for you
or how you are in your situation in general
because I mean you can
of course not increase it, yes the
financing costs really increase in the
end what losses is the situation
you are in  so
the market environment then let's take a look at the situation
today has a
certain
problematic complexity yes
this exactly as you say the interest rates have actually
gone up you could actually
get more for your rented apartment but this is
not possible due to the regulations here if
you refinance yourself you have doubts
buy more and
maybe doesn't have a buyer or
background and is demanding, yes, but it
also shows whether you've thought about it in recent
years or whether you
've perhaps planned with foresight
We sold it a year later
and then of course we
built up cash reserves and what we have
done in recent years is we have
also grown in width,
so we
looked at other locations, other countries
and others in the
real estate industry  Asset classes
such as industrial real estate,
where the rents are basically indexed,
so you are participating in
this development and you also have
long new long-term loan agreements
or something like that, you have to
grasp the company a bit, so you don’t get any further with sales,
so how much  Turnover makes the
several corporations, so
nobody can say that because turnover is complete for us, so it
goes up and down
because it is basically due to the sales
when you sell or buy a real estate portfolio
and so on
hundreds of
millions, but also significantly
lower, yes, but that's because
you sell a building portfolio over the years, you're
rich, then that's already over 100
million sold, I think
three, four, five years ago, I sold 300 million
or something, okay, that means
yes, and what about that, yes
hopefully higher always so so so
high it's already 20% or something like that,
unfortunately you can't generalize like that
I don't want to
name every detail here either, but they were,
well, they were enough to live on,
yes, but when we talk now, we can't
pass them on  for a 3% margin no, of course
not, you ca
n’t buy what I’m buying, yes,
there is such a golden one,
roughly, yes, a project
developer or not, build for a margin of less than 15%,
yes, and I, well, you
already have higher meshes, especially with the real
estate portfolio  build up because
of course it happens over years,
sometimes over 5 or even
longer and then of course you do,
uh, let me say at the exit
according to Hohage yes, but of course you have to
calculate for the
different years but okay
not so bad maybe it is also
true  okay so in the end it's
all for you too now after the
first two three big jobs
i love
my work and i find
doing this project and so on and also to come up with
new ideas sometimes
to go to new countries and  then
somehow to be successful or something like that that
's
really fun for man America too yes
we made a portfolio then
sold it and also
made money there America we have, uh,
we are active in the solar picture so that's what it's
all about  from Florida over to
Texas and so on or are three four
locations Florida somehow a
couple of thousand miles really accurate but
we are just only one four locations
okay right
you so the market has just kept
growing more and more erm it has
certainly inflated  and at
some point it reached a level where a
mixture of two different things
happened, i.e. high prices,
hardly any deal flow or only at a very
high level and on the other hand,
regulations that are becoming ever stricter,
and then at some point the returns were
pushed down a lot  and then
we just or I
said to myself we have to stop in we have to
open up new markets yes and I was
just interested also invested against the
euro to his dollar and
then just did a few things
we went to Milan do there
uh  real estate trade we are
represented in austria
starting in berlin i understand that you
know the area the feeling you
started with the first apartment in
tegel and then you know the only thing
but if you go to the us now or
sun world or there different locations
how do you get  a feeling for what you are
buying, so we usually have partners on site,
the further away the
investment is from here,
we just look for partners or have
the partners, so people in America in particular
who I know
do it then  We then invested together with a person of trust there,
which was good when
I bought Austria a few years ago, then I made my decision a few years ago, then I
met a lot of people on the road,
I bought another house for my
parents and there were very good partners
from friendships and then
opened a strong local partner to other locations it's
always been a people business with which
René Bänke is also connected, so to speak,
business because he's a
bit of the model what you explain
only in Austria um no they are
not connected and B  is a different
model as far as I can see through it,
because in the end we work
with our own money and we do
n’t have the large volumes like
Sina or something like that, so your own money in
the room means you
also do a lot with banks now, but  with our own
equity so the exact
investors in and capital really
had our own equity but then
financing our business is relatively
simple yes so the several goes because
I am the only shareholder there is my
money in it and logically we have
banks with which we are very happy and
long-term  work together and if
you why did you set up an AG for
several AGs, why, then, I had
considered at the time whether we should
do something like going public and so
on, which I then saw as not
suitable for our group
and then we let it go  it's
also better in perception but
now has more prestige reasons in the
sense that the
jokes are somewhere else or something like that
or are listed on a stock exchange
that's actually just the weigh how
you put it together early on so  if
you say don't sell
that they are in the same area you have
them yourself have a structure in terms of
prices or it's best if
you build up a real estate portfolio, which
is very homogeneous in itself, yes, that's
why he said we always
did a lot in Berlin  yes, we
mainly bought rental houses or
similar projects with a suitable structure, i.e.
rental houses, residential complexes and so on,
often paid attention to the similar year of construction
classes, so now less so
mixed, for example, 17 years of building
old buildings or something, yes, and in the end a
homogeneous product, yes  and then
we also did earlier, for example, that we
divided everything up,
so the goods that created the land register pages were
sold by developers or something like that and of course we are trying to do it
in NRW, which is a
bit more difficult because you come from
there but you know that of course
very motley market, so
small houses,
big houses, residential complexes back and forth and
that's actually better if you
buy larger stocks together, that they
are easier to manage and
then basically put them together as a portfolio,
these tiny six party houses do
n't really make sense
for  a portfolio okay but what do you have to do so
how many good is there such a thing in
NRW I know like 20 30 units per
property or something like that okay
I'm not looking now so
of course we have a good investment
transaction team they do that and
I would now  not in five parties
but in 20 party houses
I look at the follow-up or
something, yes, but I do look
at our projects regularly, especially
when things get bigger and
especially when I work with them or
talk to banks and that's how I'd like to be
know what we have okay where do
you want to go so somehow there is a
guy who sort of
started and now we are talking about
a very large portfolio so um
object probably already big
it's just like that
I mean we are not the biggest
investor in Germany  On the
contrary, I can give you a long list
of people who
do a lot more and have been around for a lot longer
and have a lot more extensive stock
for me it's done that way but fun
my being my hobby for once
so it's in a completely different league
of course
I am  I don't know exactly, I'm guessing
500,000 units or something, but that
's a completely different type of company, I
said that to you earlier, we
're called Meeren AG, but in the
end I'm the sole shareholder, which has something
to do with it  has that
we would like to work independently
yes and if you are of course listed on the
stock exchange or something like that you can
already in a tight tight corset yes
put forward by the shareholders yes and
we will try uh now or I do
n’t want to do it myself so that’s why so few
stock exchanges listed
me  it's fun i think
i like the real estate business i like getting to
know people i like
exchanging information about viruses exchanging information about the economy
have met great people
through the business yes and yes
like you said yes i think what
you need in life yes that's everyone
everyone can do it  Answer the question yourself
yes, you can live wonderfully with 5000 euros a month
yes and I had
certainly achieved that a few years ago
but what matters to me is that I
can do it again somewhere on Monday morning yes and one of my biggest
hobbies  It's just simple to
implement it correctly Having an idea
is absolutely right, but when I
say let's go there, buy, I have
no idea about
this, that, and then try to
present it successfully, if you've
done it then
it fills me with pride  and I'm
happy to say that, yes, and uh, I'll say that in
a somewhat general way
because I
used to ask myself what drives me anyway,
and on the one hand it's the
idea of ​​freedom, so I
like to let people tell me what to do and what to do
because of that  also the question what
about insta why are you doing that it's
just fun point the end yes and
um if not everyone likes it now
like I said I don't want to step on anyone's foot
but just do it like that but we're
talking about 120,000 lost or
something  I think no yes I think yes
and meanwhile by the way an active
community I saw a question
that people from your community may
want to know if you are currently
still shopping so I would also like to
know yes
come home today yes
laugh at the navel of the  World in
Gelsenkirchen
the key data were good and the condition
was reasonable also with regard to all
possible energy-related renovations
everything
yes
as far as I know yes ok then
your team comes and tells Gelsenkirchen
a template so that’s how professional we are then, yes,
an area a
million after that  as before we
certainly buy with a more
healthy sense of proportion than two
years ago when you just tried to
get into the market yes now
you look closely through the whole thing
of course the new or
future interest rates have to be applied so if
that just happens  calculates and that does in this
specific case there is more or less
a limit to eating, so
we'll do that today too, yes, we
recently bought an industrial
property that was in Witten,
we also bought it there
before we continue to buy abroad
especially in Austria where business is still
going well we are also looking
at Berlin as well as what we did recently and
so on it
is a time for good
opportunities but it is also
a time when you have to think carefully about
what you are doing and  We are also
on the seller side at one point or another
because we also
say okay, we will take profits with us,
just raise reserves and see that we
are well positioned for the future, yes
industrial plant, then
first
report any rental income to Witten and then
you can  just pass this industry on,
I can't look into the
future either, but
making industry mobile is usually something different.
We really buy one from
oldschema, that is, in the property
that we can optimally develop in the long term,
see that we have
strong tenants there
at one point my tenants don't
develop the stock either, look at that we
put up long-term contracts and then
you'll have a cash flow-positive property if it all works out the
way I said
and then you're
not so
obliged to do that now  to
make an exit yes and we will see that we are
growing successively so that we
are just right okay the question is always
how long yes so we are frankly
I am married to a single
property so that's um
that's kind of a  in my opinion
i don't have that i have that
now i would also
sell my jacket to you if you get a
good price now yes that's how i see
it with real estate yes but of course we have
different pots and
different strategies some are
short-term some are  more long-term
and if things are going well some are
maybe also a certain way open
end
your community wanted to know in the end yes
I saw
how can you benefit from the current
market situation or the
question is there is a lot of
dynamics and a lot of upheaval and that  there are
always phases, we can well
imagine where the chances will be on
the way, so I think that
at the moment
the best thing you can do is to
really keep calm and
not try to put
all your eggs in one basket  yes because
the market is undergoing an upheaval there has
not yet been a clear bottoming out
in the living area in my opinion and the
interest rate landscape is still
moving I mean what
happened last weekend was the weekend
before so the Silicon Valley Bank then
credit Swiss and so on if  if he did
n't react well to it now
so question marks how this whole
takeover went but because
now I don't think I
reacted in a united way I think
you would have noticed a little movement that you have to
look at now so that's why
I would rather a little
In spite of everything, restraint or in restraint recommend
a good opponity that's why I
said earlier we'll also buy today
if it pays off today if you
also think about it okay what about a
doubt coming up or
mandatory energy measures
what do I get there for rent today what
can I get  I might start renting tomorrow
and then at the end the surplus will be enough
or is it attractive enough
then in my opinion you can
still buy today this year which many
people forget so they
like to exaggerate upwards and they
always like to exaggerate downwards  So
in the last few days, before the
interest rate hikes and worse things
started with the Ukraine, I got
some bizarre e-mails every day or
messages about what kind of
projects people want to do now,
well, I didn't understand it from start to finish
what the
prices are now and where or somewhere the
business case is yes and the same
people would have no idea a
year and a half later the
opportunity to enter the market very cheaply
for a view
of maybe five or ten years but
not because they stop  somewhere down there are
worried that the world is going to
end yes and I think
you can take this worry away from people
and the interest rates are not
historically high now so we are not talking
about 12% interest or something yes but
we are talking about in the 10th  Annual range four
percent and if you just say now
or four and a half or something like that if it
's ten years now financing and
you just buy a well-positioned
band location or just a good
reasonable location in Berlin a
property bring your own funds with what
you need real estate business then
you can  I think I'm
doing good business today and maybe also
knowing that things will go down for a few more
months, but
you've made an investment,
yes, because I think
it's very difficult to anticipate the low point on the market,
so we'll get back to what
I did  The entrance says when I started
real estate, many people
smiled at me, but at the time it was
n't really my intention to say I'm going
into real estate now because I know that
10 or 20 years from now it's going to be somewhere else,
but I
went into real estate because I had some money
had earned on the stock exchange and because I said
okay, that's a
reasonable investment for me and then
I'll close the circle to what I
said before, so if you have 100 200
300,000 euros eK today and invest it sensibly,
then you can do it  In my
opinion, to generate a return or
surplus that you
can basically live on in the long term, yes, and that's
why the time to
invest is not necessarily wrong, it
may well be that things
will go further down, but I believe that we are
now experiencing a total crash and
Germany
somewhere  I don't see it ending on the siding,
quite the opposite, I mean
Germany, a strong industry, a
very strong medium-sized company, maybe
sometimes a bit confused
thinking about politics, but that's a
different topic, but the FDP is exactly right,
even if it's a member of the FDP, okay and
support them where I am  can because of the
possibility that I like politics, or exactly, first of all, I am
always trying, I am a
freedom-loving person and
also support a
freedom-loving
democracy or party and try
to be tolerant
can
then if not everyone
spits the soup yes and that has
unfortunately become more and more common in recent years
so that everyone
somewhere tries to have a say
okay you have to do this you
do that and so on
I don’t like that yes  and that's why
I support the FDP, even if I do
n't like the other one right now, but
that's the party that
's the most liberal for me, that represents the center
and um, yes, for me, I've been
expecting
it to have been supporting all kinds of projects
a lot for eight years  Children,
street children, disabled children, I try
to support all sorts of people
who, in my opinion,
need help and ideally
in the local area in Berlin and the surrounding area are okay,
but it's okay with you, so on the
one hand you're socially committed, so to speak,
and
you try to take it on your side
I buy it, there are pictures, um, I've
seen your team gave you
a golden Blackberry as a gift, so to speak,
that's funny, yes, that's
a symbol is a symbol
and unfortunately it's not really made of gold, it's
made of gold  only
gilded but it was busy at the time that
I
worked very early on with the Blackberry
and had real estate offers sent to me
and I was able to
react very quickly and was able to
make good opportunities and the brokers
understood very well why I was
sending him an offer to buy immediately  or
say I want to buy the mobile phone but it
really was in my Blackberry in the end
I actually invented the world
but I was there I'd say a
pioneer so
you're obviously
on the road very intensively so if you say
okay there's an offer  and you are,
so to speak, the first Blackberry to
answer immediately with I'll buy
you can imagine the frequency with which
you bought here last year,
no, again, I had to at the
beginning of my career or especially
in the first ten
Going my own way than he did so I did
n't have a name in the market I was
n't the wealthiest yet and could
score with any huge bank statements and it was better for me
if I said I'm just quick to
try the very good
opportunities on these  vaccinated
to react quickly and then bring in tolerability there as quickly as possible
and that's why I did
a lot with my Blackberry back then,
had a lot of my technology
on the go because we're talking about
the
2013/2015 yes, there, there, there
was  no iPhone at all and so on
but you are bullish on Essen so on
the area where they are I'm glad to
hear that well NRW is not bad in general
so you can in NRW so first of all I
like the attitude people there so
they all have a grown
business somewhere  attitude then it is that real
estate there is by nature
much cheaper and many
people there simply have to do with real estate
and the market is more volatile then
you somehow have a catchment area of
18 to 19 million people that's a
big market  it is not yet so
over-regulated, which is also due to the fact that there are
simply rental apartments and if
you look at the area in
North Rhine-Westphalia, for example, and compare it with the
locations in eastern Germany,
the prices in eastern Germany are
sometimes higher, but the rents are two to
three euros cheaper  per square meter and I'd
rather buy in
Gelsenkirchen or in Essen or in
Dortmund or in Wuppertal or
something with a sensible consist of
a good WLAN or maybe thick
better from a lot of development so
the whole Silk Road issue with the
ports there and so on we have on the
Try to buy an umbrella there
and we can see that we
can rent it out well, and that means
we can help, for example, because Dortmunders are
out and about, we've done a few things, yes, it's
not a luxury renovation, we're not
the investors who are now trying to build a
house in Essen  to buy somewhere to
install marble bathrooms and get a 20 € program
again but it's enough for us
to buy in the house that's rented for 5 €
wants to make the booth there reasonable and
then we get our 8 € or 8 €
then it's worth it for us  we
have one and that's that's our
business
invested or something like that I was one
of the initial investors in habit that
's now the world's
largest provider and so on
we still have it because I'm still
joking in it and so on
we do but in the end it's somehow above
every topic what comes out below
real estate or real estate wet
so
the next real estate project you've
followed that that he's back again we
've borrowed a lot of money we
think real estate is a mess yes but
those were ours so something like that  never
been our world so I work with
my own money and I don't like to
lose money yes and I of course
it's kind of impressive here too if
you look at this whole story in
a way but I
wouldn't put a horse on it and
say  okay there is an option now that
i will be a billionaire multibillionaire with
some kind of investment or i'll end
up with zero and that was never
my world so we've been trying or
i've been trying
to be a clean entrepreneur for the last 21 years
to do our business at the end of the year
Making money and not having some kind of
huge burn-ray where I
have to fly somewhere to Saudi Arabia
and collect money
is not my business so my
business is making money and
I need to become the richest person in
the world  but what
happened then I could
imagine that the manager magazin
made
2000 apartments existed,
that is half of the so the 2000s
we have logically we have a
four debt so clearly every property
we own or at least
mobias system then there is a wage on it but
so
I would have to look at the numbers again
I don't have them to hand right now
of course not
okay so anyway you can
imagine there's that quite
a few flowers have ended up with you in the last few years
I have to so okay I
buy live so  of course logically
already money out that means also being
able to invest privately or just
private real estate so clearly
private houses or something like that
you have to
take a close look at Instagram there
’s something on the Mediterranean
okay but now tell me exactly where then
I don’t have any peace of mind anymore  so
you are you are also traveling with other
influenza so she is the
scene so my friends but that has
less to do with insta or what to do are
just my friends so I
noticed one that I hope you saw
that you know polarized so to speak
but  so yes in fact but
very very cool i can tell you okay
it is very special in what he does
a really very nice core and
also my friend
got into one of my fears and
longtime friends of julian he
is uh a lot in this  insta scene
back then and has built up a
lot of fitness and lifestyle companies for
25 years and so I know
a few people there but to be honest it was
unintentional so
I still choose my friends
for sympathy and not for
money and  lost
recommended highly recommended yes
well
i learned a lot as well as an
incredible journey well what is possible
if you have the right timing and
the right motivation it seems that
you can make a difference yes i
think you said one thing that that
I noticed in retrospect
ask what was what was my
recipe for success or something yes then it is
certainly timing yes but you mustn't
forget when I bought real estate in Berlin
I wasn't the only
Berliner but one of three and a half
million and timing counts though  also
the willingness to implement things and
I didn’t start with a lot of money,
yes, but and at that time there were
rental houses, so there were 12
party houses or something like that, they
cost me €112,000, so I could have done others, yes,
but I have to manage a lot of them
at one market  let it be um
ah no Max on the ground Berlin is falling
apart BZ front page now tear
down all the empty houses and so
on it's not nonsense yes and I
did it anyway yes and that's
a bit of this topic so timing
yourself a plan  do it and then
implement it take a close
look so what exactly is it then I
believe it is then I do
n't think so
if we turn the markets back a year and a half there
were
90 percent of the voices who said
real estate is great and great and here
and everything cheap and  the market is
booming and that has already changed,
so if you
look at any magazine,
the mood in real estate is very bad,
but if you take a step
back and say you
always wanted to buy my property,
you wanted to invest money, you wanted
reasonable interest  then have it
somewhere around 6 7 8% maybe
uh you don't necessarily have to
have it out on the Kudamm but maybe it's enough
in Essen or wherever then
now the time has definitely
come when you have money and
now you don't  somehow needs all the money from
the bank and wants to finance 110%
and a knight of fortune is certainly
now a time when you
can look at the market and
deal with the market and look at all the issues related
to regulation and when
a good return comes out  and
the bank also says and the banks are still
financing that they do that
you can buy real estate now and
then, in my opinion, you
might have to put the newspaper aside
and then maybe next year
the market might have another five or
ten  Percent has just corrected his
business plan for the next 5
or 10 years and I think that's when
you do it sensibly or if you
want to buy a condominium today yes then it's certainly a
better
market environment to buy provided you
don't have money you say
financed at 100% or something, but
maybe you have 100,000 or 150,000 of the 400,000 euros
that the condominiums cost,
then today there is
a very good good market for it, yes, but
I can't look into the
crystal ball because it's the present
day  the markets are so confused and
networked and so on
and nobody knows what is happening with this
entire Ukraine crisis escalating which
hopefully cannot
cool down somehow question marks like what is
happening with inflation which is
hopefully going down what is happening with
interest rates is inflation going up or will
it stay  high must be counteracted
what are
construction costs and so on back and forth so
there are so many topics that
just have to keep an eye on at the moment but
despite everything I believe standing still and
doing nothing was never the right
option and when I
look at the last 21 years  our
company history and also in my life
I was actually never inactive for a year
no matter what was whether Lehman was
rent cover was
when there was a curve or or yes they were
all crises that actually many
people lived through and still
acted sometimes more but sometimes less
and  somewhere always try to approach things with a sense of proportion,
yes,
in my opinion, that is exactly the same as what will happen in
the next one or two years,
yes, and wait for the absolute perfect
time,
so a year and a half ago you could have
timed the time perfectly,
namely at the total peak whether  you've
done too well with it now but it's
an open question yes you're well
financed or something else but
many don't have to be done do you think there
are many
resumes like yours or
careers like yours that you just
don't know about because they don't now
take place so publicly but what does
man say the volume the prosperity you've
had for the last 20 years there are
now 100 or 500 people who
have it similar, only nobody knows about them
so there are of course many
careers that have had different states than
me, well, they  maybe we started with
one with better
foundations, yes,
but I have
a large circle of friends
who have made it from nothing to significantly
more than I have, but that is
also
where most of the CVs are or
many are somehow known in the
Real estate world I always thought it's
such careers are very very
rare but I think that many
just aren't like me which
is also okay yes you
can't feel like it's fun
to say yes
I always enjoy it yes  some
some just don't some don't want to
go public but you
already have a
few hundred people in Germany alone who hear that yes
I don't know a few hundred now
but I know at least 50 plus people
who have certainly made a similar career
and  I'm sure it's also
significantly better than me, so that
means we're talking about somehow
owning several 100 or 1000 objects
or something like that,
still a closed
orange that's not so comparable to
this startup world where you say
made an exit and have
41 here  .25 million earned but
of course you behave a few
things covered and so on but yes there
are so I have friends who are
certainly more permanent billionaires and
they also built it up on their own
millionaire billionaires billionaires yes
but I can't name them now
because they don't want that, so we're
talking about 1 billion plus, yes, but
that's not so
it sounds hard, but if you
build up a good entrepreneur and
please
structure and
scale it sensibly for two or three decades, then that'll work  yeah wow i mean
real estate from unicorn really big number at the end there's a couple of unicorns
so to speak
what is then what is then probably now the
several AG value so to estimate
but 100 million suddenly so
I hope so but I as I said I
think that's it  Of course
you don't like to talk about such
a topic now. I know
you're very interested, of course,
but unfortunately I
understand, but I would be
surprised if they could buy this company from you
and everything behind it
is for 30 million, yes  you can do it,
well, the company has a certain
size, yes, and you
really have to go in there sometimes, so
you can't generalize that at all and
if it could be generalized,
I certainly wouldn't say it now, so
if I say 50 million
I think it is  somehow you want to sell me
no I wouldn't okay well but
[laughter]
one day I'll read then
whenever I sell something then
sell it but probably
alright all right thank you very much